Good day everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn from the BD2K Training
Coordinating Center based at the University
of Southern California.
I'd like to welcome you to our Big Data to
Knowledge Guide to the Fundamentals of Data
Science.
And today we're absolutely delighted to have
Nils Gehlenborg speaking on the subject of
data visualization, tools, and communications.
Nils is a Associate Professor in the Department
of Biomedical Informatics at Harvard Medical
School.
And he has researched and worked on the subject
of developing novel tools to visualize 3D
genomic information, as well as heterogeneous
data from large scale cancer genomic studies.
He's a co-investigator for the 4D Nucleome
Network Data and Coordination and Integration
Center hosted at Harvard Medical School.
And he's the cofounder, former general chair,
and current steering committee chair of BioVis,
which is the Symposium on Biological Data
Visualization.
He's the co-founder of Visby, the annual workshop
on Visualizing Biomedical Data.
And he co-chairs the Policy Working Group
for the 4D Nucleome Network, which is an NIH
Common Fund project.
He served on the program committees of several
international bioinformatic and visualization
conferences and held multiple editorial roles,
including his current role as associate editor
of BMC Bioinformatics.
He's contributed to the "Points of View" data
visualization column in Nature Methods.
And we are absolutely delighted to have you
Nils.
And we look forward to your presentation.
[INAUDIBLE]
Hi everyone.
My apologies for being muted for a second.
Apparently my software just detected new hardware
and put a dialogue on my screen that I didn't
see.
So let's try this again.
I hope you can all see my screen.
Thank you very much for the invitation and
for the nice introduction.
So I'm here today to give you an important
warning, an important message.
If people try to sell you fancy visualization
tools that have something about 3D, exciting,
colorful, interactive scatter plots, you should
be careful and have a very close look at why
this scatter plot is in 3D and if that makes
any sense at all.
The title of the talk today about tools for
data visualization and communication.
I thought a little bit more about this.
I first thought I'm going to tell you about
out of all these exciting, cutting-edge tools
that we have for different data types.
But in the end, I realized that BD2K is such
a broad audience.
And there is so many people doing so many
exciting things.
And there's so many different data types that
I couldn't possibly cover all of them in this
hour that we have today.
So I decided, instead, to interpret tools
as tools that you can use to figure out what
is a good
visualization tool and what is not such a
good visualization tool.
And also, how can we use visualization to
communicate?
I'm going to cover those things.
And I'm going to give you a quick overview
of this outline here for today.
I want to start with use cases for data visualization
and how visualization works.
I'll talk a little bit about how we use visualization
to encode data for visualizations.
I'll talk about common mistakes that we make
all the time and that we see all over the
place once we know that they are mistakes.
And finally, I want to emphasize how we can
use visualization for communication.
So, Use Cases for Data Visualization.
Let me start, though, with the question, how
does data visualization work?
And this sentence might be more than you expect.
Visualization uses perception to free up cognition.
What the heck does that mean?
So I'll give you an example.
Here is the sequence of human insulin.
These are 110 amino acids.
And I'm asking you, is there a proline in
the sequence?
For those who do not know what a proline is,
it's a P in the sequence.
And what you are going to start doing right
now, unless you know that there is proline
in there, you'll start to scan the sequence
sequentially.
You start at the top left and scan through.
If show you this and ask you if there is a
proline in the sequence, you'd say yes right
away without scanning anything.
So here we're using pre-attentive processing,
and I'll get into that in a second, what that
means.
But you can use visualization to make information
jump out.
In this case we're using a color to encode
a letter in the sequence.
And it allows us to perceive these letters
without sequentially scanning this scene in
front of us.
And this is an example where we're using perception,
rather than cognition, to interpret data.
And that's what visualization allows us to
do.
And in a way, another term for what visualization
is it's an external cognitive aid.
And it allows us to augment our working memory.
And I have another example here that I think
is very insightful.
So when you learn how to multiply large numbers
in fourth grade or third grade, you learn
this technique where you're adding them up,
step by step.
Well, you multiply and then add them up, step
by step.
So that is another example for an external
cognitive aid.
We're externalizing information, putting it
out in front of us, so that we can think about
what matters and then break the problem down.
That's one thing visualization does as well.
Here's another example of how that looks.
If I give you two functions then ask you,
do they intersect?
Do they cross 0 anywhere?
Again, what you need to do if I show you this
table, you need to try to figure out what
the shape of these curves is for these functions,
for two of them.
And figure out if they might be intersecting.
If I just plot them, you can look that up.
So your eye beats your memory in here.
And you're able to answer these questions
much faster.
So that's how data visualization works, in
very basic terms.
Now, how do we use this?
How can we exploit the fact that we now can
externalize things, that we can offload work
to our perceptual system?
So one example is, and I'm going to use a
quote here that I think almost everyone has
said at some point in their life, I believe
it when I see it.
And we don't know who really came up with
that first, but it's certainly an important
question.
And I want to give an example why that matters
or why that is related to data we [INAUDIBLE]
So here's something that many of you probably
have seen before or know about.
And that is Anscombe's Quartet.
Anscombe's Quartet is a set of four functions
that upon initial inspection with some simple
summary statistics appear to be identical.
All four of them have the same mean for X,
the same variance for X, the same mean for
Y, the same variance for Y.
They have the same correlation between X and
Y.
And they also have the same linear regression
line.
This data set is small.
By looking at the numbers, you can see that
they are not the same.
But imagine this was a data set with hundreds
or thousands or hundreds of thousands or millions
of rows.
You would think you have two or four identical
datasets.
Maybe they're not sorted the same way if they
look different at the top.
Let's plot the data and see what happens.
Here is Anscombe's Quartet plotted.
And we can see very clearly that these functions
are not the same.
And this is an example of using visualization
to confirm an assumption that we have about
data.
And the trick here is that visualization can
be used in a way where it's completely unbiased
to any underlying assumptions or models that
you might be applying here when you do statistics.
And this is why we can really explore data
and look at the data in this way and hopefully
not make mistakes like we would have made
if we have just used summary statistics.
And this is thanks to Francis Anscombe, who
was a statistician.
Another use for data visualization is when
you ask yourself, well, are there any patterns
in my data?
And that is where we're using data visualization
as an exploratory tool to generate hypotheses.
And we will visualize data and then start
looking for patterns such as trends, or gaps
in the data, outliers, or clusters.
And then start to reason about why these things
are there.
Why is there a gap in the data?
Did our measurement device not work?
Or is this really something that happened?
Was there just no signal during that time?
So this allows us to generate hypotheses.
And then once you have a hypothesis, the next
step is to try to come up with statistical
or computational approaches to follow up on
them, particularly in large data sets.
But this is the first step.
When we're doing data during research, we
have to come up with hypotheses after we have
generated data.
And that's why data visualization is so important.
And it's getting so much more attention these
days.
Because we need to come up with good hypotheses.
We're not collecting data just to test the
hypotheses.
We just start with the data.
And we need, as a first step, to come up
with new hypotheses.
And so that's why we are really interested
in having good visualization approaches.
Finally, there is a third use case for data
visualization.
And that is nicely summarized by this quote
by Napoleon, "A good sketch is better than
a long speech."
It's also known as, a picture is worth a thousand
words.
And there is a wonderful example for what
that could mean.
And it also involves Napoleon.
It's Napoleon's biggest defeat.
So this is a little bit ironic.
Napoleon's march in Moscow, I'm sure many
of you have seen this.
This is an infographic by someone called Charles
Menard.
He lived two centuries ago.
And he created these figures based on data.
And in this example, you can see the size
of Napoleon's army marching towards Moscow.
It's the light brown line or orange line that's
getting smaller and smaller.
And then the way back, when they were retreating,
the black line gets even smaller.
And there are interesting things you can observe
in here.
The size of the army somewhat correlated with
the temperature dropping as well as situations
where they have to cross rivers.
That always leads to large losses.
And this figure is pretty famous.
So I'm not going to go into much more detail.
Now visualization use-
[AUDIO OUT]
And there are also different kind of situations
in which we use visualization for these things.
For example, so we can always go back and
forth between all three options.
And this is, in fact, what we do all the time.
But we also need to be aware that, for example,
when you're looking at confirmation-exploration,
this is a dialogue between a computer and
an analyst.
But when you present data, you have a dialogue
between an analyst and an audience.
So there are some differences.
We would use different ways of looking at
the data.
We have different needs for our visualizations.
And I'm going to get into that.
And we'll come back to this at the very end
of the presentation.
So to begin with, if we want to visualize
data, we need to somehow take the values in
the data set and turn them into something
visual, something graphic.
And this is the step where we encode data
for visual representation.
And I want to give you an example of why we
really need to think about how to do this
and why that matters.
And so there is a wonderful paper by a colleague
of mine, Michelle Borken, one of my colleagues
at Harvard.
She studied visualization of arteries in the
heart to diagnose heart disease.
And the paper is called "Evaluation of Artery
Visualizations for Heart Disease Diagnosis."
And the question that they were trying to
answer is how to best visualize something
called endothelial shear stress.
That has to do with the blood flow through
the arteries.
So it is apparently so that there are areas
where you have low endothelial shear stress.
You get build-up of plaques.
And they're dangerous.
And where you have higher shear stress, that
is
less risky.
And so there was a new device that is able
to actually get data about where there is
high shear stress and low shear stress in
the heart arteries.
And they set out to compare the existing approach
of visualizing this information to a novel
approach that they developed.
And what they found was pretty striking.
Although, it may not be surprising for someone
who's familiar with data visualization techniques
and approaches.
So I want to walk you through this real quick.
Traditionally, the heart arteries are visualized
as these blocks, rectangles.
Essentially, they cut open the artery and
rolled it out.
And then they plot it on top the shear stress
measurements.
High shear stressing, in a sense, is better
actually.
It is indicated by red in this example.
And low shear stress is indicated by blue.
And that is where danger situations can arise.
So that is one way to look at this artery.
The other way is to have a 3D model and map
these shear stress [INAUDIBLE] on top of it.
So this is the starting point.
As I said, this is the traditional 2D projection
and the traditional 3D projection.
The first thing that they did is they asked
clinicians, what color map would you actually
like to use to visualize this kind of information?
And lo and behold, the first choice of the
clinician was this rainbow color map.
And the second choice was this option F, here.
So the reason why they picked the rainbow
color map is because that's what we see all
the time.
We know what that means.
Fair enough.
So let's go with this.
They also explored the second choice, which
was this color map which had for low values,
bright reds.
And then it goes to black and white for high
shear stress regions.
That was the first thing that they did.
So for example, what you can do now is you
can map the new color map on top of a 3D model.
And as you might know, 3D models are great
if you have them in front of you.
You can touch them.
It's hard sometimes to interact with them
when you're on a computer screen because that
screen is two dimensional.
So in order to see all sides of this model,
we have to rotate it.
We have to zoom in and out, potentially.
And that's all an effort that we have to put
into seeing that.
So they came up with this very smart way of
representing this artery tree.
And that's this one.
So they create a two dimensional representation
that still has pretty much the same information
in it.
They are using this two dimensional artery
as a representation.
But what they did, in addition to just showing
a rectangle with equal height across the whole
rectangle, is they actually indicate the diameter
of the artery by shrinking and scaling the
height of the rectangle along the way.
So they have a pretty good idea where the
arteries are wide.
And we have also a pretty good idea.
And the other advantage is we simple do not
have to rotate anything.
We just look at the screen and we can see
it.
So this is a wonderful situation to be in.
And you'll see in a second why that really
matters.
So here's a new visual representation.
And they asked a set of about 20 medical students
to identify problematic areas where there's
low shear stress or regions that indicate
that this patient is at risk of heart disease
and serious, potentially fatal problems.
They asked them to look at four different
types of visualizations.
The one that I'm showing you right now, this
2D representation of this novel color map,
they asked them to look at the same 2D representation
with the rainbow color map.
And they also asked them to look at the 3D
projection with the rainbow color map and
with the new color map that I'm showing you
here.
And the results were striking when we look
at the percentage of areas of low endothelial
shear stress that the medical students identified.
When you compare the 2D maps between the two
color maps-- so the new color map is a darker
bar, the lighter bar is the rainbow color
map-- when you compare these two, you see
there's a difference.
91% of all low ESS areas that were identified
in the 2D representation with the diverging
color map.
And only 62% were identified in the 2D representation
with the rainbow color.
And it gets even worse when we look at the
3D model with the two different color maps.
71% of all low ESS regions identified with
the 3D model and the diverging color map.
And only 39% percent were identified with
the 3D model and the rainbow color map, which
is what clinicians have been using.
So as you see, there are statistically significant
differences in terms of the ability of these
clinicians or medical students to identify
these areas.
And
Now, the work that Michelle Borkin and her
colleagues presented there is based on a solid
understanding of what utilizations work and
which ones don't work.
And that's why we can see that there are indeed
big differences.
If you do your job well when it comes to visualization,
it matters.
So this is my motivation to tell you a bit
more about how we can encode data and why
it really matters to get this right.
Here is a very simple taxonomy of data.
I'm not going to spend much time on it.
We start out with data.
It can be tabular data.
And we can get categorical or ordered data.
And ordered data, itself, can be ordinal or
quantitative.
So ordinal is simply ordered.
And you can have categories like ordinal,
for example, and quantitative data.
We can also do some algebra and compute on
it.
Additionally, we have relational data.
That means links, such as networks or trees,
between different types of entities.
And we also have spacial data.
So spacial data is data that comes with an
intrinsic position in space.
Whether that's absolute or relative doesn't
matter.
You can imagine, for example, the location
of atoms in the protein structure.
MRI data, spatial data.
And x-ray data is spacial data.
Those kinds of things are spacial, because
they do have a real world representation.
Everything to the left of spacial is abstract
data.
And that's where we are completely free to
choose encoding, because there is no real-world
representation that we would know of.
know of.
So with relational data you can imagine--
on the other hand, if you talk about this
like a rodent network, that is spacial data
that has some relational aspects to it, for
example.
But it's important to distinguish these two
things from each other.
And now we can ask how can we encode data
when we have data falling into these different
categories.
For example, we can start thinking about categorical
data.
We're asking questions like, what is it?
Or where is it?
And we can use a plane and place items, data
points or objects on a plane.
And depending where we place them, that assigns
them a category.
So you can imagine you are cleaning up your
desk in your office and you make three piles
of paper-- stuff that goes into recycling,
stuff that needs to be filed, and stuff that
you really should have done yesterday.
So there are the three categories very clearly
distinguished from each other.
It's very easy to figure out what is what.
We can do the same thing by assigning colors.
In this case what we have to use, the component
of the color model here is hue.
And commonly, we would refer to this as the
color of an object.
Shapes can be used in broad categories.
And then we can order these things with respect
to how accurately we could recall that information,
which category was assigned to an object.
The best, most accurate encoding is really
position.
And when you go to shapes, that gets very
problematic.
At some point, when you go to shapes with
many corners, it gets pretty tricky to distinguish
them from each other.
It's the same with colors.
And we'll get to that.
Relational data can be encoded, for example,
by using something called containment.
It can put things that belong together into
the same area and things that do not belong
there outside of that area.
I can use connection, which is what we typically
do.
We're going to think about node link diagrams,
for example.
Similarity is another way to encode this kind
of data.
And again, our fourth option is to use proximity.
Things that are closer to each other belong
together.
And things that belong somewhere else are
further away.
So again, there is a way to word these.
I think it becomes more obvious how important
it is when we look at quantitative and ordinal
data.
So the most accurate way to convey that information
in the way which makes it easiest for us to
recall what is the quantity or what is the
value here is to use positions on a common
scale.
We can also use positions on unaligned scales,
where we have the origin of the scale move
in space or on a plane.
We can use length of objects.
We can use angles or tilt.
And maybe you already started thinking about
bar charts and pie charts.
Area can be used to encode quantities.
Curvature- I've never seen a really good visualization
that would use curvature, but it's possible.
Volumes are used very often.
Unfortunately, that's not a very good encoding.
Remember the PCA example that I showed you
in
the beginning?
It also used size of 3D spheres on a flat
screen.
Lightness can be used, how light or dark,
how much like that in the grayscale.
And color saturation is another option.
But color saturation really is not a good
choice for quantitative data.
Maybe you're thinking now, wow, we're using
heat maps all the time, for example, for gene
expression data or other similar data.
And yes, we are using that, or lightness.
But we should not be using this for any quantitative
data.
Whatever we want to encode or show with these
things should be done with qualitative.
So here's the ranking.
And you can also then look across these different
data types and different encodings and you'll
see, depending on what you have, certain things
will work better.
Other things won't work as well.
So it's very important to think about the
encodings that you want to use when you start
working with data.
And I want to give you one example, just another
simple example, where we can see what a difference
that can make.
So you might all be familiar with these kind
of diagrams where we're using circles with
numbers in them and the intersections of circles
to encode some overlap of sets.
So this is from a paper that was in Nature
Communications.
It doesn't really matter.
This was called a Venn diagram.
It turns out, in fact, this is not a Venn
diagram.
This is actually an Euler diagram.
There is a slight difference.
In the Venn diagram, you show all intersections
that are possible between your sets.
And in an Euler diagram you just show those
that actually exist.
And so this example an is not a Venn diagram.
It's an Euler diagram.
And when we try to interpret the data the
first question is, what is the biggest intersection?
And now what happens when we look at this,
there are a lot of numbers.
So you would sequentially go through and try
to find all of them [INAUDIBLE] this one,
and try to remember which one is the largest.
If I would to ask you, what is the distribution?
Is there one really big one and then it's
fizzling out?
Is it normally distributed?
Or what sort of distributions do we see here?
You can try to do this, but it's not straightforward.
You need to look at all the numbers and try
to remember.
Because this visualization does not convey
this.
This, in fact, is a non-area-proportional
diagram.
You can only make these Venn diagrams area-proportional,
so that the area corresponds to the number
written in the area for up to three sets.
Beyond that, you can't even do that.
But the problem here is, even if they would
now look at these areas, what we are using
to encode the area is a shape.
Sorry, to encode the number we're using an
area.
And these are all areas of regular shapes.
And all these are not the same.
It's not that they're all circles that you
could easily compare.
They have all sorts of shapes.
And if you go back to this example, area is
not a very accurate or useful encoding for
quantities.
This is pretty far down the list.
It's even worse than angles, which we are
using in pie charts.
We all hopefully know that pie charts are
not good at representing data.
good at representing data.
So what can we do about this?
So when we apply our principles that I just
talked about, how to encode data, we arrive
at something that looks like this, for example.
This is an offset plot, where we encode the
size of the intersection in the length of
a bar and in the height of the bar.
So you can make a bar chart and then place
below the bar chart a little matrix that shows
which of the sets involved are intersecting.
And I can now easily answer the question,
which one is the largest intersection?
In fact, it's not even an intersection.
In this case, we're looking at SNIPs that
were called by the four different callers.
You can see there's one caller that generated
an awful lot of SNIPs that none of the other
callers found, which is MAQ.
You can also start organizing these bars in
this bar chart now that we are free to reorder
them.
We can order them, rather than by size of
the bar, we can root them based on the number
of sets that are participating in the intersection.
And here we see, for example, a lot of these
larger intersections actually have two or
three sets in them.
There's the outlier with one set.
We're only looking at a single set.
And the case where we're looking at all four
intersections is actually pretty easy.
But this is just another example to show that
when we apply the proper encoding, we generally
end up with a better visualization than if
we just encode the data in a way that maybe
looks better.
As you've seen, we often have many data types
and many ways to encode them.
And so how do we pick the encoding that's
the best, that's most effective here?
And so there is something called the Principle
of Importance Ordering when it comes to picking
encodings.
And that says "encode more important information
more effectively."
This is a quote by Jock Mackinaly.
For those who know Tableau Software, Jock
Mackinaly was a data visualization researcher
for many years.
And he co-founded his very successful data
visualization, data analytics, and visual
analytics company.
But he has done very fundamental research
in that area.
And that's probably one of the reasons why
they're so successful.
Now, Ranking of Encodings.
So the first question to ask is, how accurately
can the data be read the visualization?
But there are other things to consider, for
example, when you talk about categories.
You want to be able to discriminate them from
each other.
If we have lots of them, we need to know how
many categories our encoding can actually
support.
So discriminability, for example, is a question.
Before we get there, and I apologize, I want
to briefly show you another example for the
encoding for the scenario where we're looking
at accuracy and what problems we can run into
even if we have great encoding.
So a typical example, we have a table, a bunch
of items, and we have a couple of categories.
And now we can ask all sorts of questions
about that.
For example, we might ask or we might be interested
in what is the total
value for each item.
And we can look at it like this.
And so this is a stacked bar chart.
So that works pretty well if we're primarily
interested in totals.
Now a question that becomes much harder is,
for example, to see what is the contribution
of category 3 to each of these items?
Now we are looking at these green areas, green
sub-bars within this bar chart.
And we need to know which one of those is
the longest.
They're not very different.
We can see from the table.
But one of them is longer by 3 units than
one of the others.
So the first one for item 1, the value for
the green one is 18.
And for item 5, the value for the third category
is only 15.
But to see that is not that straightforward,
because these are not aligned to each other.
And so this visualization might work well
if you're really primarily interested in the
total.
And that's the key thing you want to know.
But if you care more about what are the contributions
of these categories across the items, if we
want to ask that question, we can now answer
that question very easily when we use something
called a layered bar chart.
We have multiple bar charts that still would
convey, somewhat, we could still tell which
one is the largest one.
It's not easy, but we can try to visually
add it up here.
But this representation is much better to
see our distribution within each category.
And finally, there's also this option, the
grouped bar chart, where we want to know or
we care more about how do these categories
contribute to each item.
What is the distribution of those?
Are they all roughly the same or are they
very different?
And that can be achieved with this grouped
bar chart.
And the point I want to make here is even
an accurate encoding is not going to get you
a perfect answer.
There's always a trade off like this one where
you need to understand, not only what are
the values that I care about, but also what
is it that, ultimately, we want to communicate
here.
And so you can't have it all, unfortunately,
with visualization.
There is very rarely an optimal solution.
There are often acceptable solutions, but
they will not answer all the questions perfectly
well.
In addition to the accuracy of visual encodings,
you can look at channels about preattentive
processing.
And so this is a little test.
I hope this is going to work on this webinar.
I'm going to show you a couple of slides where
we have these little visualizations, where
we have a couple blue dots.
And it will flash up several times, for about
250 milliseconds.
And sometimes there will be a red dot or red
circle and sometimes there won't.
And for you, just try to see whether you can
spot that red circle among the blue circles
as this is happening.
So let's just try this real quick.
So nothing, nothing, there it is.
There's another one.
I hope you were able to spot this.
This is pretty easy.
Because color is a property that can be processed
preattentively.
Remember this from the very beginning when
I showed you the insulin sequence and asked
you to look for prolines.
So with color we can really exploit our ability
to see certain things without sequentially
scanning the scene in front of us.
This is the idea that something really jumps
out at you when you're looking at it.
So we can do the same thing with shapes and
circles.
Do you think that's going to work?
I see a lot of question marks, imaginary question
marks over imaginary people listening to this
presentation.
But let's give it a try.
So I'll flash these scenes for 250 milliseconds.
And sometimes there will be a red circle among
red squares and sometimes there won't.
And let's see if you can spot it.
Just pay attention.
Did you see it?
There's another one.
So the answer is you should able to see it.
I hope some of you did.
It is known that shape is a property that
can be processed preattentively.
And now let's try one more thing, where we're
combining two possible encodings.
So we can use shape and color.
And do you think you'll be able to spot the
red circle among the blue circles and red
squares?
And for those who at least saw the red circle
among the red squares, you can be hopeful
that you might spot it here as well.
Let's try it.
You probably are disappointed because it is
not possible.
So once you start combining different channels
for encodings, shape and color, preattentive
processing breaks down.
It no longer works.
That's something we'll come back to at the
very end of the presentation as well.
[AUDIO OUT] --problem.
So that's something to keep in mind when you
pick an encoding.
And also whether we can separate channels
from each other, that's another problem.
For example, if you have two very small areas,
like two very small circles, we might not
be able to tell what color they are.
So that's something to keep in mind if we
combine these.
Or if we have a very small circle and a very
small rectangle often it's not possible to
really distinguish them.
So these things break down at some point.
I'm being told I have to stand closer to the
microphone.
Hopefully, it works.
What we're going to talk about now are common
mistakes when picking encodings.
The first step here is to look at colors and
color maps.
Rainbow color maps are all over the place.
And I've already demonstrated that they are
not doing a good job.
What is the problem with rainbow color maps?
Well, first of all, with rainbow color maps
there is no natural order.
Well, there is a natural ordering.
And that's the light spectrum.
It has a natural ordering for the rainbow
color map.
But it's not something that we are intrinsically
aware of.
The colors are ordered in red, orange, yellow,
green, blue, indigo, violet.
That's something I have to think about and
try to remember this nice shortcut, ROYGBIV,
to do that.
So hard to order, it's not clear how they
strictly order.
Look at the grayscale color map.
It's very easy.
There are two different ways of how you can
order a color map.
Well, you can order them in one way, and then
you can say either dark is the smallest value
or dark is the highest value.
And it's very clear how they are relative
to each other.
Rainbow color maps have a problem with resolution.
For example, because our ability to distinguish
different green hues from each other is much
worse than distinguishing other [INAUDIBLE]
and even lightness and contrast from each
other, we cannot see this ripple pattern that
you see in this figure when you look here
at the very top.
There is the ripples.
But you don't see them in the rainbow color
map, because we cannot distinguish these greens
from each other.
It has lower resolution, actually.
Although, you'd think, well, there are more
colors, you can get better resolution.
But you can't.
The same is true for artifacts.
So if we encode a linear function that goes
from 0,0 to 1,1.
That's a linear slope going up.
You can do this with the grayscale, very clear.
This is linear slope going up.
If you use a rainbow color map, you start
infusing artifacts.
And it looks more like it's a step function.
Because you see red, yellow, green, and that
looks nothing like the actual shape of the
curve.
It would just be a straight line that increases
steadily.
Other problems with rainbow color maps, for
example, it doesn't have a natural zero-crossing
built in.
If you apply this to something where the zero-crossing
is important, you do not see the zero.
So here's an example of mapping these two
elevations in the Gulf of Mexico in Florida.
So you would not want to use that rainbow
color map or rainbow encoding to determine
where the water starts and where it ends,
because you simply can't see it.
It's just yellow across the board.
And that's why we use different types of color
maps when zero really matters.
Another thing to keep in mind is, color is
relative.
And many of you, if not all of you, will remember
the black and blue dress or the white and
gold dress, depending on which one you saw
in that picture.
So we perceive color relative to its environment,
to the surrounding colors.
And there are some examples.
For example, we can make two different colors
look the same, here in the middle.
Both browns for the higher one and the one
in the lower rectangle look the same.
But when you put them next to each other,
you see they are not the same.
And we can do the opposite.
We can take two identical colors and make
them look different by changing the background
color.
Why does it matter?
It matters because we're constantly using
heat maps to encode our data, particularly
the large and big data sets.
And if you try to read anything quantitative
off of these maps, to begin with, it's bound
to fail.
Because it's very bad encoding, as I showed
you.
It's not an accurate encoding.
And on top of that we have this issue that
colors that might look different or the same
are actually often not.
Because again, it depends on the background
color and the surrounding color.
So these two colors labeled with an asterisk
here are the same color, same value.
But they look totally different.
Here it looks like a larger value.
And here it looks like a lower value, but
it's simply because of the context of this
palette.
Discriminability of colors, as I pointed out,
is a problem.
So in general, you can assume 6 to 12 colors
can be discriminated.
But you often have to have more categories.
And here's an example where that fails.
You see, on the left hand side, we have mouse
chromosomes.
And each
mouse chromosome was assigned a color.
So there are 21 colors.
And then for something like a synteny mapping,
they were mapped on top of human chromosomes
to see which part of which mouse chromosome
end up in the human chromosome.
And on the right hand side you can just tell
that there are 21 different colors.
You can easily distinguish them from each
other there.
If you go back now to the human chromosomes,
pick a random green area and try to map it
back to the mouse chromosomes.
This is most likely going to fail.
Because we are not able to distinguish the
different greens from each other.
The same holds true for the blues, which are
very hard to map back.
Because they're no longer next to each other.
Colourblindness is an issue.
You're probably all familiar with this.
Many journals these days tell authors, do
not send us red-green anything.
Unless you have a dual encoding where you
use another visual encoding to distinguish
between them.
Because if you are colorblind, you will not
be able to tell the difference between red
and green, for example, in a heat map.
On the left-hand side is the actual heat map.
On the right hand side is the simulation of
how someone with red-green colorblindness
would perceive it.
A simple answer is to just use blue and red.
They can always be distinguished.
Color mapping, again to come back to [INAUDIBLE]
problem with the rainbow color map applied
to elevation.
If we have a simple function that increases
all the values between zero and 10, so no
zero crossing.
If we start mapping a color map, a diverging
color map that has white between blue and
red, will create artifacts.
Because there is nothing-- the way that you
map this you can see this at the bottom, it's
darker and darker.
It's getting dark.
And then getting lighter and lighter.
And then suddenly it's getting darker again.
So you think that, potentially, the shape
of this curve is something like it goes up
and goes up and goes down again.
But this is not the case.
And in particular, by adding light in between,
you can create heat maps that look like there
are striking features that are standing out.
And unfortunately, I didn't include an example
here.
But there is no such thing.
It's simply a linear increase.
But because we go through white, that will
make a very strong color contrast.
And that can be very misleading.
So here's a couple of examples of better color
mappings.
So remember, color used poorly is worse than
no color at all.
And with this, I think what I'm going to do,
I want to tell you a little bit more about
the 3D problems.
And that is shown in this slide.
So we are often faced with that, oh, couldn't
you make it three dimensional.
Because we have three different variables
to show.
My answer is no, you cannot make it three
dimensional.
And the reason why you cannot make it three
dimensional and why that generally does not
work is the following.
Here is an example, a little bit of DNA.
And you perceive it as something three dimensional
on your screen.
And the reason for this is because we are
applying something called depth cues.
So there's occlusion.
Something in
the reason for this is because we are applying
something called depth cues.
So there's occlusion.
Something in front will be closer to you than
something behind it.
So there's some things hidden.
We see differences in size of the same object.
And when we see that, then we know that's
something that is smaller.
But the same object that is bigger is closer
to us.
We can see shading.
So shading is when there's a light source.
Things that are further away or facing away
from the light source will be darker than
things that are facing the light source.
Additionally, we use something called perspective,
which you are all familiar with.
It just means parallel lines that meet each
other in the distance.
That's another indicator that we're looking
into some three dimensional scene.
And we're using all these things.
We're using size, shading, and color, the
directionality of lines for perspective.
Now all these things are things that we usually
use to encode data.
And that can lead to a lot of problems when
we try to encode data using exactly the same
kind of encodings or the same kind of channels
that we use to make something look 3D.
So here's an example.
The example is coming up.
I don't want to go into much detail.
It's a three-dimensional heat map which encodes
additional values.
For example, here we see problem number one.
We have perspective, that means there is distortion.
Things that are closer to us will naturally
appear taller and larger than things that
are further away.
So we've got to be careful with that.
Another problem that we see here is that,
of course, when there's something tall in
front of us in this 3D scene, we can't look
through it.
So there will be occlusion.
Things will be hidden behind other things,
otherwise it won't appear as 3D.
And so there are many issues like that.
So it is generally not a good idea to go to
3D, because it will cause more problems than
it's worth.
Occlusion here, another example.
This is a 3D network representation.
So you could imagine this blob here in the
top right.
We don't know what's behind it.
We know it's 3D.
But in order to look behind it, we have to
start rotating this thing.
And rotating is work.
And visualization should not create more work.
It should reduce work.
That's what I said in the beginning.
It should allow us to use our perceptual system
to see things and perceive things and to make
this more efficient.
It should not add additional manual labor
to the process of interpreting the data.
Here's another example for occlusion and perspective.
I would ask you, what is the pattern in the
data here?
Hard to answer this from this perspective.
So if we encode this differently using a heat
map, we'll see that the pattern is actually
pretty straightforward.
That is the pattern.
It's a big question mark.
These are a bunch of issues you can run into
when you pick the wrong encodings.
I want to move towards the end of our presentation
and talk briefly about visualization for communication.
So my first point I want to make is, when
we use visualization to communicate something,
for this crowd here and
this lecture, we're often communicating by
putting a figure into a paper.
And so my answer to that is, put the insights
into your figure in the paper, but put your
data into a database.
So when you create figures you are often feeling
the need, whether this is coming directly
out of our heart, to show what we've done.
Or whether it's our PI or someone else telling
us we need to show all these things to convince
the reader, I would say this is not a good
idea.
Data belongs in the database.
You should not just try to visualize everything.
There's no point in having a full-page heat
map.
Because, in the end, it's a qualitative pattern.
Often it can be represented much better than
just showing, here are all these things that
we did and all the data generated.
I think that belongs in the database.
And it is important to really focus on the
message.
This is our job in writing the paper.
It's to communicate clearly what we found.
And even when it involves data, that can be
done.
So here's an example that I to want to give
you.
Here are a couple of numbers.
And when we look at these numbers, this is
our data.
We can interpret this in many different ways.
We could look at these numbers and ask ourselves,
well, does it matter that the values in the
first row are all odd and the values in the
second are all even?
Is that the point of this visualization?
We don't know.
So let's try this differently.
So now we bend the values.
What we are really trying to get across here
is something that you will see at the very
end.
But now we bend the values.
We're using aggregation.
So we have three categories of our values.
So between 0 around 30, between 31 and 60,
and between 61 and 100.
Now we have these bends.
So it's the same data, but they are there
in three different categories.
And now we can ask, is the order of the values
actually important here?
Is that what we're trying to learn from this
data, from this visualization, that there
is some ordering of these things?
No, probably not.
If not then why don't we show it like this?
So we have three categories.
And we have their size.
And now we can see if that's clear.
But probably we start wondering, do we really
need to show the distribution of the values
in each category?
We ordinarily just care about the number of
elements in this category, which would look
something like this.
So here are four visualizations of exactly
the same data.
And each of them can lead to completely different
interpretations of what is that message that
you are trying to get across.
In this case here, the message that we want
to get across is, there are relatively few
values in the middle range here.
So there are very few in the category 31 to
60.
That is the message.
And that is very clear.
So we have nothing that distracts us from
that.
We're not distracted by an order or by any
specific values, which we can see those very
clearly in this example.
So we're going from something very unfocused,
where we could interpret all sorts of things
into the visualization, to something that
is very focused on the message.
And that is very important.
So there is another more data-driven example.
When you have something like gene expression
data, you can
So there is another more data-driven example.
When you have something like gene expression
data, you can always plot a heat map.
And that's what is always happening.
Because a heat map is a very universal approach.
You get a good number of genes, for example,
and a good number of conditions plotted.
And you have to cluster the heat map.
You can bring out some patterns.
But it is not very helpful when you have 1,000
or 5,000 rows in your heat map.
Because there will be over-plotting.
Even if you look at them on a screen, a screen
has about 1,000 or 2000 pixels, maximum height.
So you couldn't even distinguish them from
each other.
So in that case, if you have that many values,
you maybe care more about what clusters are
there.
And then something like a dimensionality reduction
approach would work much better, because it
brings out the clusters more clearly.
And I think that should be your message in
that case, if you want to really show all
of the data, that there are a number of clusters.
Because then the profiles, you cannot make
them out anyways.
So that's a solution for many profiles, a
lower resolution.
There is less information, of course, when
you do dimensionality reduction.
On the other end of the spectrum, on the left,
we have very few profiles.
And maybe we would want to indicate there
are some really subtle differences or we care
about the shape of these profiles.
You can use parallel coordinates or [INAUDIBLE]
line plots.
And we can get the message across there.
But you have a lot of downsides there.
Because there is over-plotting happening.
When there are too many of these lines, it
becomes really hard to follow the lines.
That's something we need to keep in mind.
The same thing is true for networks.
This is a node-link diagram representation
of the network.
A network is simply a graph data structure.
It's something that doesn't necessarily have
a visual representation.
And then you plot them.
This example is a node-link diagram, where
every node in the graph is a circle.
And then you render lines between the circles,
and then they are connected in the graph.
If you care about the connectivity of individual
nodes, maybe the circular layout is good.
You just order the circle or the nodes based
on how connected they are to other nodes in
the network.
We can see that all of them are highly connected.
Well, in the other layout, this force-directed
layout, we get much better focus on which
ones are highly connected among themselves
and which node is a hub.
So the central node is in here.
Pick your layouts correctly.
And you should also never forget that a network
doesn't have to be rendered as a node-link
diagram.
That's one way to look at it.
You can also look at it as an adjacency matrix,
where we can see different things.
For example, in the adjacency matrix, you
don't have a problem of lines crossing each
other.
You can still, if you're on the bottom right,
you can see very nicely that there are is
a cluster of highly connected nodes in this
network.
You can
also see this hop at the top.
This green node in the top-left corner has
a lot of connections to other nodes, which,
among themselves, are not necessarily connected.
The downside of the adjacency matrix is it's
very hard to trace a path between two nodes
that are not necessarily directly connected.
And to answer that question is fairly easy
in a node-link diagram.
But it's really much harder in an adjacency
matrix.
In communication, we should also always remember
that how we lay out information or data in
front of the user can convey a message.
Here we have four things that are equal.
They have equal weight.
There is no clear ordering to this.
Let's get into it.
You could interpret some sort of ordering.
This is pretty much the same thing that I
already just explained to you.
Let's focus on the message.
So we can use Gestalt laws to convey this.
So here are two pairs of things that are being
compared to each other.
Now by simply moving the middle close to each
other and leaving a larger gap between the
two groups.
Here we have something that is sequential.
We go probably from left to right.
There are four steps, or four time points.
It is important to think about that.
In your visualizations and visual representations,
what is it that you want to convey?
And to go back to this, if you publish in
a journal, there's always a problem that there
is not enough space to convey it in the way
we wanted.
Keep that in mind.
There is sometimes a way around it.
Another other thing is to not overly use color.
There is something called the data/ink ratio.
So if you maximize this data to ink ratio,
you will get much better figures that are
not distracting but focus on the data.
And finally don't shout at your audience,
like I'm doing right now.
Take it back.
Try to think about what is important.
What is the message you want to get across?
Reduce, for example, color and unnecessary
embellishments, like making a 3D effect or
drop shadows.
If your message is simply to say, there are
two things the As and Bs, that leads to what
the outcome is, your answer.
So there is a big difference when you compare
these two slides that I just showed you.
Here I think we get a much better idea of
what the message might be.
And with that, I just want to come back to
my starting point here.
This dialogue between computer and analyst
is something where we need as much data as
possible.
Because we do not know what the story is that
we might want to communicate at some point.
So that's why we want to have access to almost
all the data in the world we could get.
But that is not true when you go to present
it to someone out there.
You start out with all of the data that you
can get your hands on.
You use visualizations or other data analysis
approaches to come up with some insight, something
that you've learned about your data.
And then when you
communicate it, you strip it down to only
the data that is necessary to get that message
across.
That is the big take-home message of my presentation
today.
And hopefully, the different kinds of approaches
to figure out how to visualize data well help
you next time to try to come up with a good
data visualization, whether it's for exploration
or for communication or for confirmation.
Thank you very much.
Nils, thank you.
That was a really outstanding overview of
many of the things that people should be watching
for as they're trying to communicate the message
of their large-scale data.
As we collect more and more of it, we need
effective ways to concisely present that information
to an audience.
They may not fully understand the scale and
scope of that big data, but we want to get
those messages across.
And I was curious because at the end of your
presentation you had talked about the data
to ink ratio.
And I know that Dr. Tufte has been one of
the biggest advocates for that.
Can you make some further comments about the
importance of that in helping to streamline
one's graphics to make sure that they don't
violate that?
What are some rules of thumb that one might
use?
So one example is when you create a bar chart.
So think about, does it matter if each bar
is a separate category?
You already, by separating the bars, you need
to put color on top of each of these bars.
And this is pretty much the example that I
showed you just now.
No, we probably don't need to put colors on
each of these bars, because we want to distinguish
them from each other.
That's taking place simply by having four
separate bars.
Now a different story here could be, we do
have a second variable that we care about.
So here's April, May, June, July.
Maybe we care about the fact that in April,
let's mark the months where we had a snowstorm.
I think it's probably not going to happen
in Boston this year.
But then we would have months with a snowstorm
that we would need two colors to maybe indicate
snowstorm or no snowstorm on top of these
bars.
You really don't include any unnecessary things.
If someone asks you, what does that mean?
And you don't have an answer then remove it.
You should really remove it.
Ask yourself that question about everything
you put in your visualization.
Why is it there?
It has to have a reason to be there.
Otherwise, it's an unnecessary embellishment,
like 3D effects.
In fact, 3D effects can be pretty harmful.
Because we get darker colors, for example,
at the bottom of the bar.
And they get lighter towards the top.
So if we really care about the values and
length of these bars, but having darker colors
at the bottom might draw more attention to
the bottom of the chart, rather than the top
where the differences are that we might want
to highlight.
And so there is a really wide range of mistakes
that we tend to make often, because tools
suggest that we make that mistake.
So if you make the standard bar chart in any
of the many spreadsheet programs out there,
it'll generally not take this mantra to maximize
the data to ink ratio into account.
It'll give you nice colors, for
whatever reason.
There is probably a good reason for that in
other worlds.
But as scientists and science communicators,
we really want to be accurate.
And I think, for us, the need to make our
visualizations exciting so that people look
at them, there is often not a reason for that.
Because people will look at the data, because
they care about it.
It's not something that we need to convince
them, to look at the bar chart in our paper.
They have a natural inclination to look at
it, because they want to know what you did.
It's different if you're trying to go out
into the world and draw attention to a problem
in the world.
And there is more of a reason to think about
how do we get attention.
But I would argue that getting attention is
always second to getting data across as accurately
as possible.
And I think that is a great point.
That's a great point for us to end on.
Because we're at the top of the hour.
I want to thank everybody in our audience
for joining us today.
And Nils, I want to thank you for giving us
a very useful guide of how to represent our
data graphically, and in our papers, for maximum
effect.
And I want to encourage everybody to tune
in next week when we have-- actually, next
week we will not be having one.
Our speaker had a health concern and so has
had to cancel on us.
We'll try and find another time to schedule
something with that speaker in the future.
But for next week, we will not be having one
of our data science seminar series.
My deep apologies for that.
But, at any rate, I hope that we will see
you again in the future.
So thank you everybody, and thank you Nils.
Thank you very much.
Bye, everyone.